you might know Maddie Ziegler from being
the golden girl on Dance Moms but what
you might not know is that the days of
being her dance teachers favorite are
over that's right even Abby Lee Miller's
favorite kid in the entire world isn't
saved but what happened well over the
years it was revealed that Maddie
completely stopped talking to her dance
teacher she doesn't even acknowledge
Dance Moms anymore
why stay tuned and you'll find out show
me the monitors Maddie's time on Dance
Moms so in order to understand what
might have led to Maddie and Abby's
falling out we have to start at Maddie's
time on Dance Moms
Maddie has always been the favorite kid
Abby always said that she was the one
that always applied Corrections and
delivered a fantastic performance that
made her proud to be her dance teacher
this sometimes obvious favoritism drew
the other moms crazy like seriously they
frequently fought over the fact that
Abby spent more time with Maddie and
let's not forget that Maddie was almost
always at the top of the pyramid - there
was definitely a lot of jealousy
involved but Maddie didn't care about
that all she wanted to do was dance over
the years more and more kids came to the
Abby Lee dance studio to be the next
Maddie
some came pretty close to succeeding but
Maddie remained irreplaceable even after
she left the show and tried to be
replaced about a million times we know
several of the Dance Moms girls who
would have happily have the next Maddie
written in their Instagram bio not gonna
happen girls not gonna happen
but as Maddie spent more and more time
away from Dance Moms her disdain for the
show grew there were many reasons behind
that and here's one of them
Abby jail time everyone was shocked when
it was announced that Abby Lee Miller
was going to jail
she faced jail time for fraud after
hiding more than 750,000 dollars in
earnings why is that bad because she
didn't disclose that income to tax
authorities reports state that she
allegedly smuggled from as much as a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars into
the u.s. from the Australian tour but
Abby claims she never saw that money she
was asked to people who were traveling
in her carried some of that cash
themselves to which she replied that
it's debatable we'll talk more about who
she's allegedly framing for that later
Abby was originally rumoured to be
sentenced for five years in prison
later her sentence was reduced to one
year and one day which she served but
let's go back a little in fact let's go
back to the moment that pretty much
shocked us all Maddie leaving Dance Moms
when the jail news hit Abby's world
crumbled and it crumbled even more when
it was announced that her fave dancer
was leaving the show this season
Maddie's not gonna be on the team
anymore seriously if you haven't seen
season six of Dance Moms you have to
because it's by far one of the most
explosive seasons ever
Maddie leaving had a huge impact on Abby
but something else also happened in
season stakes Melissa Maddie's mom
finally stood up for Mackenzie
Kenzie was always getting picked on by
Abby for not being as good as her sister
and it took six seasons for her mother
to stand up for her but what's important
about this moment is the fact that
during that confrontation Melissa said
she knows so much stuff Abby doesn't
want to mess with her right now as this
happened after Australia and during the
jail news it's safe to assume that
Melissa seemed to have known something
about Abby's situation after all she was
her assistant wasn't she keep on
watching to hear more about the theories
about her involvement but first let's
check out some other reasons why Maddie
and Abby are no longer speaking Abby not
letting it go Dance Moms fans have
noticed that after the Ziegler's left
the show Abby was still way too attached
not just on the show but also on social
media
unfortunately Abby doesn't tend to say
if she misses them or at least she
didn't back in the day instead she
posted several weird comments over the
years that kind of shaded how the
Ziegler's were treating her for example
when Maddie was featured in Sia's video
the greatest Melissa posted a picture on
her Instagram underneath Abby commented
that she actually asked Melissa if SIA
needs a bunch of kids for dance parts
and Melissa at the time said no it was
clear that Abby wanted to include
herself in Maddie's career and recruit
her dancers and it seems like Melissa
really didn't want her to be involved in
2018
Abby became more active on social media
and with that came a lot of subtle
messages one of the fans commented that
they can't imagine how it must feel to
put all that energy into pee
and just watch them walk away their full
comment indicated that they were talking
about the Ziegler's Abbi replied to that
comment and thanked her for realizing
the situation she's in which implies
that as a dance teacher
Abbi got way too attached to the
Ziegler's but maybe their relationship
just wasn't all that healthy in another
example where she just can't let go of
the Ziegler's walking away Abbi
screenshotted one of their private
messages she got in it the fan said that
they're mad Maddie won't even admit she
was on Dance Moms anymore
Abbi posted a comment saying that
forgetfulness won't be forgotten or
forgiven she also added that she devoted
hours of extra special attention for her
she also admitted she gets many of these
messages every day and in September 2018
Abby showed her new revenge ring she
said it's revenge for cancer but then
added she wants revenge for a few others
people have quickly noted that the shade
was most likely thrown at Melissa for
the way she treated Abby after dance
moms tough childhood after leaving the
show
Maddie slowly began to open up about her
time on Dance Moms
just because she was the favorite it
doesn't mean she had it easy the
Ziegler's revealed how social media
became hard for them after they received
plenty of bullying messages throughout
their childhood both of the kids were
also incredibly overworked and not even
notes that it's ridiculous just how
stressed out she was during that time
she says that they lived through it and
she doesn't feel like she has to watch
the show she added that there was just
so much drama that she never wants to
see it again
Maddie also said that she was stressed
at 11 years old which definitely
shouldn't happen and it's true when you
live and breathe competitive dance you
have zero time for a brief Maddie's
childhood was dedicated 24/7 to dance
and to pleasing her dance teacher who
could turn on her at every moment even
though Maddie was a favorite she wasn't
immune to Abby's wrath sure it didn't
happen as much as it did with the other
girls but it was there their mom Melissa
also notes that the girls have missed
out on a lot of other things because
they had a strict contract Maddie and
Mackenzie weren't able to book other
jobs despite becoming gradually more
famous she also revealed she didn't want
to deal with all of the drama anymore
because it got to the point where it was
too strong
pole-dance is supposed to be a happy
thing right it's clear that the world of
competition was taking a toll on
everyone and if that's not enough try
having your teacher yell at you most of
the time as you're rehearsing fans
theory is that the Zeigler simply became
too resentful of Abby's toxic behavior
after Dance Moms from Shady comments to
feeling entitlement to be a part of
Maddie's projects Abby seem to have
demanded a lot many are defending her
saying she deserves respect after
dedicating so much time to making the
Ziegler's who they are today but others
say that there's a fine line between
support and being toxic and by the looks
of it the Ziegler's decided to block out
Dance Moms from their lives to avoid in
a future toxicity but is that all
because the Dance Moms fandom has a
rumor that Melissa might be slightly
more involved than we think
Melissa's involvement so here's what the
dance mom rumor mills states abby often
post cryptic social media messages in
one of her Instagram stories which
addresses the European Q&A tour the
Ziegler's did Abby says people shouldn't
waste money on a Q&A to talk about me at
the bottom of the post she added that
you shouldn't give her any cash of
course her assuming Melissa which is
pretty much indicating that Melissa
could be more involved in this whole
Australian money debacle in one of the
promos for season 8
Abby also screenshotted an article which
showed a photo of Abby with the moms and
what did Abby do she whited out Melissa
come on ABS what's going on
well these theories might shed some
light on what kind of issues Abby has
with the Ziegler's and vice versa pan
theories all of the current Dance Moms
theories were beautifully summarised by
a reddit user strict door it's important
to note that these are of course just
theories and should be taken with a
grain of salt these allegations have yet
to be proven to be real or fake but we
love a good theory so let's check it out
ready here it goes in summer 2016 Abby
was advertising several ALDC la master
classes claiming that Maddie was going
to be a part of that Maddie wasn't there
and people who took those master classes
felt like they were ripped off Melissa
got involved and made sure Abby cannot
publicly mention Matt
ever again and vice versa the redditor
also notes that the distance was most
likely advised by their legal counsel
and management being close to someone
who's going through so many legal
troubles is bad for Maddie's career so
what if Maddie was legally advice to
just leave Dance Moms out of everything
to avoid being linked to Abby it's clear
that Abby was going to use every moment
she has to try to get back in contact
with the Ziegler's
and then there's the currency smuggler
theory the redditor alleges that Abby
had some of the moms and the girls
smuggle Australian money through customs
and since Melissa was extremely loyal to
Abby at the time she would totally do
this for her another theory around the
money issue states that Melissa is
suspected of helping Abby bring in large
amounts of undeclared foreign money
since Abby wouldn't want to declare all
her money and risk losing it to the
banks where she fraudulently filed
bankruptcy
she and Melissa take it the suspicion is
that Melissa just held on to the money
instead of returning it to Abby
if Abby tried to collect it legally it
would mean she's a part of the whole
scheme so the safest thing to do from
Lissa was to completely distance herself
from Abby of course this is just a
theory though so take it with a grain of
salt
another theory states that Abby could
have done something to Mackenzie the
Dance Moms subreddit took a screenshot
of a facebook conversation with Melissa
in which he states that Abby did
something bad to Mackenzie fans weren't
able to figure out what happened or if
this was all just behind the scenes some
even suggest it has something to do with
Mackenzie's music lawsuit after Abby
signed her to a music label that failed
to deliver their contractual promises we
all know Kenzie blocked Abby on
instagram after Abby said she's unable
to tag her on any of the photos so it's
clear that although a beloved these kids
the relationship seemed to have been
unhealthy maybe Abby herself doesn't
realize what happened and why but
sometimes walking away makes more sense
and since both Maddie and Mackenzie
aren't talking to Abby it really could
be that they were legally told not to
you have to admit Abby does a lot of
shading on social media and that's not
really healthy right do you think Abby
should have celebrated Maddie's success
instead of asking for recognition or are
you on Abby side and think that Maddie
should have acknowledged Dance Moms more
let us know in the comments below and
that's it for a video don't forget to
subscribe to the themes for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]